come stanno le vostre relazioni
non solo le relazioni familiari le
vostre relazioni sociali come stanno i
gruppi con i quali voi vi trovate a
lavorare a fare sport a cercare di
costruire una società più giusta una
comunità
se non coesa almeno più inclusiva
ecco un tema importante relativo all'era
del cambiamento del mutamento
dell'innovazione è quello delle
relazioni delle relazioni sociali del
sociale come dimensione nella quale
trascorriamo tutta la nostra vita
e qual è la società nella quale noi
stiamo vivendo oggi in italia nel 2015
ci sono 158 anziani ossia persone oltre
i 65 ogni 100 giovani ossia persone al
di sotto dei 35 anni
e 55 persone in età non lavorativa ogni
100 in età lavorativa
questi sono i dati dell'ultima
rilevazione del 2015 a cura del nostro
istituto nazionale di statistica
allora questo è un dato molto importante
unito ad altri due
la media dei figli per ogni donna
italiana è arrivata a 1,2
arriva a 1 e 3 grazie al contributo
delle cittadine straniere ma per poter
avere un vero ricambio generazionale
dovremo superare
la 1,35 figli a testa
siamo ampiamente al di sotto per poter
garantire un ricambio di generazioni e
dunque la piramide come ci insegnano i
demografi dal punto di vista della
costituzione della nostra società più
giovani meno adulti e ancor meno anziani
sta andando e andrà sempre di più verso
una costruzione
esattamente opposta per i dati che vi ho
sottoposto brevemente poc'anzi avremo
pochi giovani sulle cui spalle saranno i
capi tanti anziani del livello più alto
allora qual è il tipo di società che
riusciremo a costruire e come possiamo
pensare di portare cambiamento se non
badiamo alle relazioni alle relazioni
che sono presenti all'interno della
comunità nella quale viviamo comunità
che fatta di tante comunità comunità di
pensiero comunità di intenti comunità di
valori comuni tecniche che compongono la
comunità nella quale noi viviamo questa
foto di steve mccurry mi ha molto
colpito è stata scattata a kabul nel
1992 dunque in afghanistan e ritrae un
gruppo di donne davanti a un negozio di
scarpe da ginnastica
mi sembra che possa come dire rendere
ben conto di ciò che ci è capitato dal
2007 a partire dalla crisi che ben
conosciamo anche sulle nostre spalle tra
il processo di globalizzazione è quello
di individualizzazione
la globalizzazione ci ha illusi che
avremmo potuto scegliere che cosa
comprare anche nelle nostre vite e il
neoliberalismo che è una tipica
conseguenza ci ha convinti che tutto
dipende da noi ma non è così
c'è qualcuno da qualche altra parte del
mondo che ha deciso due anni fa che cosa
noi compreremo quest'estate e il
problema dell'individualismo ci illude
che possiamo controllare da soli i
risultati della nostra vita
questo non è vero ci sono un sacco di
risultati di ricerca che ci dimostrano
il contrario
quindi qual è il tipo di cambiamento che
molti risultati di ricerca cc indicano
intanto dobbiamo abbandonare questa idea
dell'individualismo l'idea che noi
possiamo controllare che noi comunque ce
la faremo
molti autori ci indicano che da soli non
è possibile andare da nessuna parte
e questo ci mette di fronte però alla
necessità di dover condividere
affrontare conflitti trovare modi di
negoziare cercare di includere
all'interno di processi di negoziazione
di interessi locali diversi
che sono presenti non solo le politiche
pubbliche le politiche sociali in
particolare in italia hanno dimostrato
attraverso la grave crisi del welfare
che non esiste più un welfare nazionale
né sanitario né sociale e che il livello
locale e quello in cui si giocano le
politiche
allora i messaggi importanti che mi
piace lasciarvi oggi sono tre il primo
sconfinare trasgredire sono temi molto
noti ai professionisti che lavorano nel
campo del sociale assistenti sociali
educatori psicologi ma anche i medici
infermieri psichiatri che ben sanno
all'interno del loro lavoro quotidiano
come il lavoro necessario la prospettiva
di cambiamento non è più aggiustare le
persone
per fare in modo che possano aderire a
un sistema che è sempre più confuso
sanno bene che il loro compito è trovare
all'interno delle norme delle regole che
sono state decise all'interno delle
organizzazioni pubbliche o private nelle
quali lavorano che bisogna sconfinare
uscire da delle zone di sicurezza da
delle nicchie che ci si è costruiti e
che bisogna un po trasgredire
nell'ambito sempre del lecito ovviamente
per poter inventare dei modi nuovi
per poter mettere insieme le generazioni
l'italia è piena di progetti
interessantissimi e molto innovativi
a questo proposito poi figuratevi io
sono la prima di cinque figli siamo 33
ragazze lasciatemi dire tre ragazze e
due ragazzi io ho imparato fin dalla più
tenera età
che cosa vuol dire negoziare avere
conflitti e cercare di come dire
convogliare le energie per un obiettivo
comune
l'idea di comunità come pratica locale
oltre a quello che vi ho che vi ho già
detto presenta in italia degli aspetti
molto interessanti in una ricerca che è
stata svolta dal mio dipartimento alla
quale ho partecipato insieme
all'università di milano bicocca e altre
quattro università italiane
abbiamo svolto 100 interviste a
amministratori locali a assistenti
sociali a cittadini e rappresentanti
delle associazioni di cittadini
rappresentanti di interessi locali e ai
famosi stakeholders
qual è stato il risultato più importante
in ogni regione a macchia di leopardo o
se volete ci sono dei delle piccole e
grandi esperienze in ogni regione dicevo
ci sono delle luci molto interessanti ma
sono ancora delle isole
dov'è che funziona funziona dal punto di
vista sociale
ma anche di politiche pubbliche laddove
c'è una prospettiva di sviluppo locale
dove i trasporti nelle grandi città che
sono un contesto di sofferenza anche di
sofferenza urbana oltre che di grande
possibilità
laddove i trasporti parlano con il
sociale
parlano con il lavoro parlano e questa
idea che all'interno di piani di zona di
piani di sviluppo locale di piani
strategici delle città ha vinto la dove
ci si è riusciti a parlare e si sono
decise una o due priorità per i prossimi
dieci anni
e questo che fa funzionare e tutti hanno
lavorato in quella direzione
partecipare e fa bene era l'ultimo
elemento che vi avevo insegnato
scusate che vi avevo segnato partecipare
fa bene innanzitutto a chi partecipa e
quindi qual è il senso profondo di
questo messaggio è che quando noi
partecipiamo stiamo lavorando anche per
noi stessi
in molti risultati di ricerca che ora
non sto a citarvi è dimostrato che molte
persone non vedono l'ora sa di poter
contare b di poter dire che cosa pensano
di poter scegliere come ricostruire un
giardino pubblico dove far passare la
pista ciclabile come è possibile una
migliore raccolta dei rifiuti come
guadagnare all'interno della propria
comunità locale dall'idea che non è uno
slogan che le differenze sono una
risorsa
c'è una ricerca che è stata introdotta
all'università di harvard pensate
nel 1937 38 728 giovani studenti di
harvard che sono stati seguiti per 75
anni lungo la loro vita da tutti i punti
di vista
controllo del colesterolo
che tipo di vita hanno fatto che cosa
hanno svolto all'interno del loro lavoro
cioè quali successi hanno raggiunto
perché il tema era la domanda
all'interrogativo cognitivo era qual è
il modo per raggiungere il successo
nella vita e quali sono i fattori
protettivi e predittivi per una buona
vecchiaia hanno fatto questa ricerca
svolto questa ricerca su due gruppi un
gruppo di giovani studenti di harvard e
un altro gruppo delle periferie di
boston dove i giovani vivevano in case
in cui 1938 ancora non c'era l'acqua
potabile
qual è il risultato fondamentale
il risultato fondamentale è stato che si
invecchia bene non tanto rispetto al
valore di colesterolo persone che
stasera dovete gozzovigliare non è tanto
ma è la qualità delle relazioni si
invecchia bene se non si sta da soli
sembra banale è stato dimostrato atteso
la ricerca dell'università di harvard
comincia a studiare i figli dei primi
dei primi soggetti che sono stati
sottoposti a questo controllo ne sono
ancora vivi 60 su 728 hanno più di 90
anni stanno benissimo
continuano a sbuffare quando i
ricercatori sottopongono loro a una
serie di controlli e di richieste ma
questo è il messaggio più importante che
ci da questa ricerca
allora noi dobbiamo ripavimentare le
nostre relazioni
trasgredire permetterci per permetterci
di uscire da un disincanto
noi dobbiamo poter desiderare poter
avere delle utopie da seguire anche se
sappiamo che non è raggiungeremo questo
è uno dei dei modi in cui le generazioni
possano incontrarsi e quella parte
finale della piramide che vi ho mostrato
prima può dare vita ai giovani e spazio
ai giovani e dobbiamo pensare di
ridisegnare quelle che sono le nostre le
nostre società come vi ho fatto vedere
prima non c'è bisogno di tantissime
risorse possiamo usare anche le risorse
che già ci sono
rimettere un po a posto
andare a riutilizzarle così stiamo fra
di noi c'è chi lotta c'è chi si arrende
c'è chi dorme ed entrò nel dolce rumore
della vita ma il messaggio con cui
finale con cui vi vorrei lasciare e
questo ovviamente calvino un autore a me
molto caro anche all'interno delle città
invisibili ci dice l'inferno dei viventi
non è qualcosa che sarà se ce n'è uno è
quello che è già qui e l'inferno che
abitiamo tutti i giorni e che formiamo
stando insieme due modi ci sono
per non soffrirne il primo riesce facile
a molti accettare l'inferno e diventarne
parte fino al punto di non vederlo più
il secondo è rischioso ed esige
attenzione e apprendimento continui
cercare e saper riconoscere chi e cosa
in mezzo all'inferno non è inferno e
farlo durare e dargli spazio
cercare e saper riconoscere chi e cosa
all'interno dell'inferno non è inferno e
farlo durare e dargli spazio
grazie
elena allegri